are you doing today how are you doing
I'm good I'm doing excellent listen it's
a real thrill for me to get to talk to
you I grew up listening to your music so
I just want to say it's really cool
thank you so much so I have to ask you I
guess the most important question is it
because of Hearts song and t-shirt that
Captain Marvel crossed a billion dollars
well a god you would hope so we would
hope so wouldn't we no I think it was
just a beautiful the iconography of
having that in the film was just for us
was just wonderful and inspired and
aspirational you know just to be part of
that story of a female superhero that's
kind of a first and kind of been in the
ground floor of that stuff as long as
we've been trying to do you know strong
women musical stuff so it just fits
together in a beautiful way I hope and I
hope it helped absolutely early on in
this development process of Captain
Marvel did you know that they wanted to
use a song and feature a t-shirt and you
know it was a little ways ago quite a
while ago because my husband jeff has
kind of hooked up with some of the
people involved in the film so it was
like would it be okay you know if we
used a heart song would it be okay if we
used a t-shirt we're like would it be
okay you know
yes did you know what did they ask you
about multiple songs that was always you
know crazy on you
it was crazy knew there was a there was
a sequence that was gonna maybe have
Barracuda in it and it was I guess a an
action sequence a chase but I think they
cut that scene because they had other
ones that were better I think I
definitely want to go back in time a
little bit because I know you went on
tour with Queen yeah many years ago
they're my all-time favorite band I have
to ask what was it like touring with
them and what was it like touring with
them
that was a European tour where we were
opening and another band named Nazareth
at the time was opening two and so we
were just real newbies we were green as
they come and we were just like sitting
on side of the stage and after we'd play
our show we'd sit and watch Queen play
like right up close and and the band was
just incredibly brilliant like no other
rock bands censor before and you know
watching Freddie Mercury with all of
that energy and just each guy was just
so proficient and passionate with their
art and backstage you know they were
really cool people too and Freddie
Mercury in particular had a big thing
for Anne he was like oh and oh and you
know like he'd he'd just try to hang out
with Anne cuz he had the diva thing and
she had the diva thing so and me and um
me and Brian May were pretty tight you
know we would love to talk about guitars
and music and but they were all great
they took us to like late dinners after
the show had closed down the restaurant
stuff like that and you know had like a
12-course meal with you know wine
pairings and you know ending with the
Courvoisier from 1922
you know it's stuff like yeah so I mean
they were very elegant and not so as not
as much of a debauchery kind of a rock
band as they were very elegant very
English and very cool I would have
killed to be applying any of those
dinners so I have to ask you what was
your reaction to bohemian do you think
Rami captured Freddie from the way you
remember him yes I think Rami did just
such an incredible job with capturing
Freddie every bit of the body language
but also the emotion that comes from him
and from his eyes he you fall in love
with him in the movie in the same way
that I fell in love with Freddie in
real life because you see he's a
delicate person with the biggest bravura
in the world but there's so much you
know so much delicacy inside that he's
kind of protecting with the rovira
so yeah I thought he captured it
beautifully in movie they took some they
took some license you know with some of
the actual story but to me it just
really worked as a wonderful piece of
entertainment of really great movie
you you've toured the world I'm curious
they're like certain cities that you
really get amped up to play because of
chance oh yeah a lot of a lot of great
cities that it's that we look forward to
playing Montreal is really a beautiful
town New Orleans has its own character
all to itself and it's all about music
their college towns in particular you
really know that people are there to
listen and they're there listening for
the lyrics not just like for the party
you know sure so there there's so many
great towns Seattle our hometown you
know that never hurts if you're going
out on tour again this summer and you
want like an all-star lineup yeah you
can ask how did that thing get put
together do people come to you and say
we want to do this or are you sort of
like we want to go on tour let's see who
we can bring with us well there's been a
lot of different tours where people
wanted to put us together with
women-only sort of a lineup and we have
resisted that in the past because it
feels kind of female centric or
something to be kind of pigeon-holed
just as women you know together women in
rock but this time out it feels like the
time to do it just because of what's
happening in the culture and you know
women are coming on so so we've got
Sheryl Crow and we've got you know Joan
Jett and Brandi Carlile's gonna come out
a few times and Elle Kings coming out
with us and so um I'm really looking
forward to that
just to have a lot of strong female
energy
of their own stage it'll be fun is it
one of those things where when you have
like at the end of the show you want to
do something where everyone comes out
together or have you already have you
thought about that yet or it is not a
finale
well um usually finales are more on a in
a show where they're filming it and
everybody's kind of stuck there for the
entire show which is fun but on rock
tours a lot of people leave early if
they play early they leave early to try
to roll through the night to get to the
place where they could sleep sooner than
later so but I think there would be some
some situations on stage where we play
with each other and sing with each other
you know for I'm I'm coveting a chance
to sing with Sheryl Crow
so absolutely even if you know it's
before I go out with heart I could open
for heart to ode for yourself I have to
stop there I'm just gonna say again it
is a real thrill to be able to meet you
and Congrats on being part of Captain
Marvel thank you